if you would like to enter my giveaway
for your chance to win a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero so today we were
treated with a leaked video from the set
of spider-man far from home we haven't
gotten much from the set except for what
Tom Holland has given to us himself so
it's always nice to get a little photo
or a video and unfortunately when we do
get something it's really hard to tell
what's going on with the exception of
the last video that Tom Holland gave us
a few days ago it seems pretty clear
that he's introducing us to hydro-man if
you haven't seen that video yet you can
check it out in the link above so in
this video that a fan took it's pretty
obvious that they're in a airport Peter
Parker exits the airport and begins to
walk very quickly toward something again
without any context that's pretty hard
to say what's going on here but my guess
is that he was in the airport and his
spidey senses started tingling and that
would explain why he's walking so fast
there's clearly way too many people
around for him to just shoot a web and
swing on out of there so I'm guessing
he's walking so fast so he can just get
out of sight and go address whatever
problem is going on whether that be
Mysterio or hydro-man or anything could
be another person of the sinister six we
hope right so those are just my thoughts
again without any context to this it's
really hard to tell what's going on but
this is my guess let me know what you
all think is happening here and which
villains do you hope to see in
spider-man far from home another
reminder about my giveaway all you have
to do to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
is subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]